[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 la conversación
sobre nuestros derechos es fundamental y
se vuelve especialmente necesaria por
esa constante exposición que tenemos a
mensajes que como mínimo deberíamos
cuestionar o intentar entender
[Aplausos]
sin pedir nada especial que era un
caballero que me sepa más que entiendan
lo que no que no que no que no me toque
y que luego no Amelia dueto se lanzó a
esa tarea ellos son dos músicas
mexicanas que cantan lo propio pero que
también parodian y que rápidamente se
han viralizado en las redes sociales con
mucha audacia han modificado letras de
artistas conocidos y nos invitan a
pensar las diferentes Por ahí han pasado
Bad Bunny y Camilo y hasta Shakira entre
muchos otros
las protagonistas se conectan con ellas
hoy desde México ellas son a Sofía Garza
y Viviana Barrera bienvenidas a ellas
hoy y ustedes Lo repiten mucho Amelia
significa mujer que trabaja pero a mí Lo
que más me gusta es que es mujer que
trabaja por otras mujeres están las
parodias y también están las
composiciones propias Comencemos
hablando de lo propio qué es lo que
ustedes cuentan en su música
Bibi quieres que empiece Sí si quieres
empieza tú va va Mira bueno Primero
gracias por la invitación que para que
podamos estar este en este espacio en
ellas hoy Muchísimas gracias por
considerarnos y y Justo eso es parte de
este esta plataforma que estamos creando
Viviana y yo con nuestras letras con
nuestra música para fomentar el apoyo
hacia mujeres y entre mujeres como lo
estamos haciendo hoy entrevista
realmente este proyecto nace de la
necesidad de querer cantar unidas juntas
como un Dueto por sus familias elegimos
ese nombre Porque nos escribía
perfectamente a milla Viviana y nos
dimos cuenta que hacía falta por ahí
encontrar la manera de concientizar
tanto a mujeres o a hombres de lo que
muchas veces se canta de lo que muchas
veces se dice independientemente de las
parodias o de los tiktoks iniciamos este
proyecto con
que de cierta manera explicaban y ponían
a la mujer en una posición donde la
mujer podía tomar la decisión de salirse
de una de una relación que no estaba
bien o de cierta manera darle un twist
no a este a esta manera de siempre
victimizarnos o de no salir de no poder
salir adelante porque
dependemos de un hombre entonces fue así
como inició y poco a poco ido emigrando
en este en este darnos cuenta Viviana y
yo del poder que tenía la música y las
letras también de poder pues hacer estas
parodias y de tratar de que la gente
entienda que si vamos cambiando no lo
que vamos pensando y lo que vamos
diciendo pues vamos a encontrar a
encontrar un mundo mejor no Entonces ese
es un poco el Cómo surge todo esto y en
donde estamos hoy en día no sé si
quieras agregar algo vivir sí Y pues más
que nada digo Sofía y yo siendo mujeres
y y siempre hemos sido muy
independientes este mujeres soñadoras
también donde perseguimos nuestra
carrera por eso les quiero preguntar
también de dónde nace esa idea de hacer
esas parodias Y por qué la necesidad de
darles la vuelta a las letras de las
canciones hablemos de eso
una manera muy orgánica o sea la
realidad es que estábamos en mi casa
ensayando íbamos a tener un show
importante Sofía y yo este donde además
de tocar algo de nuestra música y vamos
a tocar unos covers y y estábamos con
nuestras parejas
y y en el ensayo pues como que empezamos
a bromear no a cambiar las letras y nos
empezamos a reír y decidimos grabarlo
fue muy natural decimos grabarlo dijimos
es que hay que subirlo porque no puede
no porque que nos salió esto en en un
ensayo tan divertido realmente lo
subimos a Pues en la madrugada no chof
fue en la madrugada y al día siguiente
teníamos así un millón o dos millones de
visitas y mil gente comentando no lo
podemos creer porque al final la
intención nunca fue este vamos a hacer
este proyecto Tan grande sí fue como
Oigan quedó muy padre la canción
y de hecho nos pasó en que estábamos
cantando la canción y no podíamos creer
que para mí para Sofía yo no sabíamos
dado cuenta de lo que estábamos cantando
para nosotras era una canción padre y de
repente le escuchamos y dijimos para
nada o sea te está poniendo como una
mujer que te que te das o sea por por
feliz con cualquier cosita que no te
exijes este que no estás en el mejor
punto de tu vida que a lo mejor no vales
tanto como tú crees o sea mil cosas que
hicimos Cómo estamos cantando esto y de
ahí nace la idea dijimos Oye si esto nos
pasa a nosotras que nos dedicamos a la
música Ni que estamos todo el día en
esto Imagínate la gente que no se dedica
la música y que Escucha canciones en la
regadera para cantar en el coche Pues de
repente cantamos cosas sin ni siquiera
nos damos cuenta de lo que estamos
diciendo
no no sé si quieras complementar algo tú
chef para darte contexto Ángela esta
canción No vas a creer Cuál es pero es
vida de rico de Camilo entonces
realmente tú te pones a pensar vida de
rico una canción misógina una canción
machista No claro que no sabes qué pasó
que tiene sutilezas de un
condescendencia que no nos habíamos dado
cuenta y que a la hora de estar cantando
Es
okay Pero por qué es conformarse con lo
que el hombre puede poner o con el
hombre puede pagar a la casa o por qué
esta vida de rico es lo que importa más
allá de lo que o sea como que nos fuimos
en un trip un poquito más este profundo
no sé por qué se dio y nos empezamos a
dar cuenta que hay guiños en ciertas
canciones otras mucho más explícitas
otro mucho otras mucho más obvias pero
que debemos de cambiar o que si la
podemos seguir cantando pero seamos
conscientes que a nuestros hijos o
nuestras hijas Les estamos enseñando que
eso es a lo que se tiene que adaptar o
eso es a lo que ella se tiene que
conformar y por eso que como dice
Viviana no teníamos ninguna expectativa
de que se volviera algo viral
simplemente fue dar un punto de vista y
empezamos a cambiar otras letras como
Ángeles Azules diecisiete años que es
una cuestión ahí ya de la diferencia de
edad y de una posible Pues sí O sea
pedofilia y demás canciones misóginas
canciones de bad Bunny y se volvió
aquello algo más recurrente y nos dimos
cuenta que era un espacio que había que
llenar Porque empezamos a recibir
mensajes de mujeres que sufrían que que
sufrían maltrato de mujeres que tenían
abuso psicológico de mujeres que estaban
en una situación no muy buena Pues me
alegra que mencione eso Sofía porque
justamente le quería preguntar cómo ha
sido el lidiar con esa respuesta a estas
parodias
Sí exactamente el efecto ha sido muy
positivo para mí para Sofía O sea al
final digo hemos recibido de todo hay
gente que le gusta mucho hay gente que
no le gusta como todo en la vida Este
pero lo más importante es que si hemos
si hemos creado algo de conciencia este
no nada más en en los jóvenes también en
los niños o sea en mi hijo de repente si
me dice Híjole mamá esto dice algo que
no debería decir y yo Exacto pero bueno
no nos damos cuenta porque es música y
la música es terapia y trae ritmo y trae
melodías y trae mil otras cosas que te
distraen y muchas veces no estás
escuchando no para nosotros ha sido algo
muy importante este en el proyecto
porque no nada más Hemos llegado como a
más audiencia sino que también la gente
no nada más nos Busca por nuestra música
también nos Busca por la por por
nuestras parodias Y eso nos da un
poquito más de versatilidad a las dos
entonces
digo la verdad es que sí ha sido pues
muy divertido también para mí Sofía la
dinámica del del trabajo cambió
muchísimo O sea no nada más nos juntamos
a componer o sea nos juntamos a reírnos
y a disfrutar y eso está muy muy padre
también o sea tienes tu lado
serio y tiene su lado como un poquito
más chistoso No no sé si tú quieras
agregar ocho Sí yo creo que
complementando un poco lo que dice
Viviana creo que nos volvimos más
conscientes de del poder que tiene
una pantalla en este caso las redes
sociales y y que vivían ellos seamos
afortunadas de tener estos esta cantidad
de seguidores en tiktok estos videos que
son virales y que se ven muchísimo pero
creo que conlleva una gran
responsabilidad entonces a la hora de
nosotras sacar nueva música a la hora de
componer ya lo hacemos ahora
completamente si ya lo hacíamos a favor
de la mujer ahora lo hacemos sabiendo
que que
tenemos una gran responsabilidad de una
gran plataforma creo que dentro de esta
diversión también hay seriedad como dice
Bibi por qué porque hemos tratado de
esos casos de mujeres que nos buscan Eh
Pues redireccionarlos a personas que
están
Pues sí que a profesionales no tanto
psicológicamente en cuestiones de la
mujer y de abusos y todo y hemos tratado
de poner nuestro granito de arena
Entonces qué mejor manera que cantando y
y divirtiéndonos tratando un poquito
también de de concientizar y como dice
Viviana es un feminismo no sé si sea
correcto decirlo así pero es muy
incluyente porque no es un feminismo de
estar en contra de los hombres o de De
estar enojadas con la vida o de decir
que todo está mal al contrario es un
feminismo que busca ver cómo podemos
integrarnos Cómo podemos Buscar esta
equidad de igualdad que tantos años se
han buscado y los que estamos haciendo
de una manera Tal vez un poquito
Cómo se puede decir a la ligera y muy
divertida pero que finalmente deja un
mensaje
miren ya para ir cerrando yo creo que lo
justo sería escucharlas cantar no que a
eso vinimos Shakira me dijeron que iban
a interpretar fuera del aire así que
tienen la palabra
Ok entonces empiezas tú como tú quieras
es que sí sí sí prefiero porque estamos
bueno Esta es la parodia de Amelia
apoyando a nuestra hermosa diosa ahí les
va
Esto está que ya no critique ni
mortifiquen y se me ubiquen las mujeres
ya no se dejan y aunque les llore ni le
suplican entiendan no es culpa suya que
se justifique Ella siempre ha hecho
música no se me agüiten ya no hay que
quedar bien con la suegra aguantarse la
y sorry quién se me ofenda nos
dijeron que calladas nos vemos más
bonitas las mujeres ya no lloran las
mujeres no grita y luego
[Risas]
hombres que valen la pena pero bueno ese
es un pedacito del último que hicimos
que nos fue muy bien la verdad estuvo
muy padre este lo hicimos a raíz la
canción que sacó Shakira con Piqué que
sorprendentemente mucha gente no estuvo
de acuerdo y y Sofía y yo lo platicamos
y es como si ella lo necesita para
desahogar algo que ella trae que vivió
que sufrió que alguien más se lo
ocasionó ella no no no no no no no lo
pidió adelante adelante yo creo que hay
ahí quisieron cambiar el discurso Ángela
de ahora el problema es ella en lugar de
que él haya sido infiel entonces como
que por eso nos pusimos a defenderla y
digo con todo el respeto a Shakira y a
todo mundo y y ahí está eso es lo que
tratamos de hacer también Siempre vamos
a defender a las mujeres y siempre vamos
a estar en pro de todo lo que tenga que
ver con mujeres Así que mil gracias por
este espacio Ángela Muchas gracias
Ángela no muchas gracias a ustedes y
ojalá podamos seguir escuchando mucho de
sus canciones y a nuestros televidentes
como siempre Gracias por estar en ellas
hoy de France 24 y nos vemos
próximamente
[Música]